Squared,
the best hope for modernization and
ultimately liberalization in the Arab
and Muslim worlds today lies in
incumbent regimes who recognize that
first of all,
economic modernization is essential to
their country's future.
How do groups like Al Qaeda operate?
It should be clear by now that in
parasitic fashion,
these groups feed off of host nations
that are weak.
It is the relief from the life in
purgatory that constitutes the average
lot of the average Arab,
that life is about unemployment.
Real rates of up to 35 and 40 percent,
and young men who when polled
consistently complained that their
existence offers no hope and no
opportunity.
It is about the fact that the United
Nations Development Program estimate
that nine percent of every business deal
in the Middle East Coast for bribes,
and when students who want to vote step
into the streets of Cairo,
they risk arrest and torture like Karim
Solomon,
who was sodomized,
tortured because he demonstrated in
favor of the rule of law.
These victims of Middle Eastern
depression are the ones who provide the
oxygen that enables al Qaeda to operate
and it gives resonance to their
political messages.